do you love star trek
stargate star wars babylon 5 battlestar
galactica
the predator movies robocop june
every other sci-fi or fantasy movie ever
made
well this is the tv and movie channel
just for you this
is sidetrek
the biggest news this week in the world
of movies is of course
the legal battle between scarlett
johansson
and disney i got to admit if you're
going to fight disney in a legal battle
it helps to be the black widow let me
put you on hold
how did all this come about well kovid
as we all know
is the gift that just keeps on giving so
basically the movie black widow which
was
really the gift marvel was giving to
scarlett johansson
a thank you for 10 years of hard work
for
being one of the main characters in the
avengers series up till now
that big thank you was smacked around by
disney
they released the movie black widow on
disney plus
the same day they released it at the
cinemas
the directors the producers kevin feige
himself
has always said how amazing scarlett
johansson has been what she's brought to
the series and
her commitment to the role has been so
impressive
scarlett johansson herself has talked
about how disappointed she is
to have to take this legal action it's
not something she ever wanted to do
the problem is however disney and marvel
studios have not
actually breached the contract legally
they haven't done anything wrong
scott johansen's team will argue that
disney have breached the contract
in at least the spirit in which it was
signed but unfortunately
this is the modern world we're living in
and this is the future and actresses
like emma stone
are potentially facing similar legal
battles
so what happened people watched it
at home and even though it had a really
good opening weekend
it had the biggest drop-off for the
second weekend of any marvel release
so far so how is this a problem scarlett
johansson
the big thank you from marvel movies
was that she got a cut of the prophet
but only the profit from the box office
the cinema release this was supposed to
be scholar johansen's big payday
big thank you but she's been screwed
over by disney plus
now scalio hansen's representatives did
try to renegotiate this deal
several months ago when they realized
this was a possibility and actually
disney plus or even considering not
releasing this movie at the cinema
at all and only releasing it on disney
plus
but thankfully kovy thing they put the
movie back a year
and we were able to see it the big
screen like all these great big movies
should be seen in other news we are
going to get another teenage mutant
ninja
turtle movie hot on the heels of the
announcement that seth rogen
was going to be producing an animated
movie to be released by nickelodeon
studios
august next year colin and casey jost
have been signed on to write the movie
this is going to be a big push by
paramount pictures they want to get this
movie out at about
roughly the same time as the animated
film michael bay
loving melody is still producing this
film so
is it going to be a remake is it going
to be a reboot we don't know at this
moment
but one thing you got to say is please
god make it better than the last one
not a big fan of michael bay i think
he's a terrible director um i think he
has a really jerky awkward style and
even though it's different to a lot of
films
i can't stand it but i do love the
teenage mutant ninja turtles
they just haven't made a decent
live-action movie since the original all
those years ago
does anybody have any idea about who or
what
this is i don't know but i'll better
never ask to look for a cat opener
so what do i say i say bring this on
and these guys are big comedy writers
colin jost has been the head writer of
saturday night live for several years
he's also married to scarlett johansson
fair play teaser
and his brother casey has also been a
comedy writer on several big shows
so one thing we can really look forward
to is
that this film might actually be quite
funny
let's just hope the animatronics and the
cgi for the turtles
is a little less creepy
empty mikey
empty
[Music]
now a film that we do want to see and a
film we don't need to see
big news this week that clerks 3
by the great used to be great kevin
smith
has gone into filming started filming on
his 51st birthday
this is a film we do not need to see for
the love of god
the first clerks was okay dogma kevin
smith
great movie christ didn't come to earth
to give us the willies
he came to help us out he was a booster
and it's with that take on our lord in
mind that we've come up with a new more
inspiring sigil
i give you the buddy christ
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's not the sanctioned term we're
using for the symbol just something
we've been kicking around the office
but look at it doesn't it pop
clerks 2 was a joke jay in silent bob
reboot movie i turned off after 5
minutes
and i never do that for films i always
stick it out but it is terrible
i'm a big kevin smith fan but this man
has lost his way
and the producers need to stop giving
him money to make films
so what do i suspect will happen with
clerks 3
it's a film we don't need to see but my
god
a film we do need to see the flash
gordon reboot
gordon's a lie now i don't always
believe in remakes there are some films
from classic movies that just do not
need to be remade
charlie and the chocolate factory johnny
depp please god don't do that again
i don't care but some films are
screaming out for a remake
and i would say flash gordon is in one
of those things it is a classic movie
but it's very much set in its time
it was quite dated so what could they do
with a remake well
if they get the correct writer and
director on board
oh they could make something wonderful
and oh my god have they so john davis
the producer
he also produced jungle cruise which
came out
last weekend huge hit massive disney
movie
already signed on for a sequel
has announced that they have a director
and a writer
tico attiti the great director of thor
ragnarok
the director that brought life back into
the thor series
hello my name is taika waititi
director actor
is writing a script for flash gordon
and now this is a bit of a project a
passion for him because
this was one of his favorite movies when
he was growing up and you can
kind of see the inspiration and some of
his later work
so can he produce a flash gordon movie
we're all going to love
oh hell yeah he can i cannot
wait for this movie and
it's going to be a corker another movie
given the green light some time ago now
was the new predator movie dan
trachtenberg
is directing and he's been talking a lot
about this movie recently
now we believed this film was going to
be called skull
but he's tweeted a little hint
that perhaps it isn't that actually
school is just a working title
and that is not going to be the name of
the movie
so what is we don't currently know but
he has been talking about the film and
what he's planning
and this looks like it's going to be a
flashback film it's going to be a
prequel to the original
one of the greatest movies ever made
good on the chopper
predator but he has been talking
this fell up quite a lot now i always
say you know you swing for the fences
you try and do the best movie you can do
and i'm sure that's what they were
thinking when they did avp requiem
was let's do a film that's just as good
as the original well
they didn't it was crap so if you're
doing a predator film
what's the goal what's the aim i want to
make a film that's at least
as good as the original and that's what
the director has been talking about
making a film that is at least as good
as the original
and better than the sequel now
if you are going to swing for the fences
i applaud you
but if you are going to try to make a
film that's as good
as one of the greatest action movies
ever made
bad idea
i'm going to do a news and gossip video
every week
12 o'clock on saturday on the new
sidetrack channel
we're also going to be doing loads of
watch alongs
reviews uh debates anything that we want
to do
and you know we really want you to come
along for this adventure it's a brand
new channel it's a brand new project
please like subscribe share it where you
can
and you know leave a comment tell us
what you want to see
in this brand new channel because it's
as much yours as it is as
thanks very much welcome to scitrek
see you soon